I will show you more oh we got some more
yeah laughs I you know hurry and I as in
a feed dunya and I'm an experiment he
was all up on Benjamin B no I'm cool
Salam alaykoum checking in with you guys
against here in mostar and look what I
found
very nice Dow Accenture amazing really
great
come in every
to have this information center people
want to know about Islam what is the
Quran who are the Muslims and if we
don't tell them who will the people who
don't like Islam will have an agenda and
now fighting against the spreading of
purpose peace
we don't share the correct information
others will share the wrong information
so let's go in here and check it out
this is our brother ankle so I'll make
Michael darling can you tell us a little
bit about this the center here and this
is centre of Education is primarily
useful Dawa for educating people about
Islam and educating people about on how
to learn the Arabic letters and how to
pronounce probably from Quran how to
read Quran and how to memorize it then
we have classes of fig is like
explanation of the religion and lot of
religion classes process here for women
for men we also have here like na
material
some Flyers posting language if you have
we are also get not doing just tower
like talk about Islam we also do a
humanitarian aid we gather clothes for
poor people we in Ramadan we we gave
like 500 if there are 500 meals in in
one month of Ramadan or we used to have
every every second day four or five
women from from our Center went to the
kitchen and they cook the meals for for
students for for worn invalids for loan
people for elderly people for poor
people and for yeah and they cooked and
then we have we have a minivan
and we went from one address turn
another one from one moment to another
and we gave that food two times or three
times a week in Ramadan so also food
workers that were working in Ramadan
they are working when it's time to eat
we go and we give them food food to it
also we are doing humanitarian aid
having some gathering of money for for
Refugees in in Syria
we also are collecting money and
building wealth in oil wells in Africa
already we are under the law we built
for of the wells wells in Africa in and
now we are collecting money for 51 and
in Gambia and also we are collecting
money to build a Masjid in in Gambia in
Africa also we have and we have school
for teaching woman how to sue you know
suing my way to suing machine so we
educate a woman in that business so they
can after they complete all curse
horses ensuing they can go and work from
for themselves work from their houses
and start making their own money you
know so that's the way we can help our
our Jamaat help our community
is there a true knowledge religion
pistol Muslim it's not the glass here
and some about ten feet also we have a
Flyers on other languages that we give
to tourists here so I need anybody
pretty much to come in here you get a
lot of courage people who are course of
course every day there is some some
activities going on I think you guys if
you're visiting Bosnia most are some of
my sense you come see ankle and
experienced the hospitality and get
educated on this beautiful way of life
hope to see you soon come up I want to
show you more oh we got some more yeah
la eternal fire no hurry and in a feed
dunya and I'm and world in her
experience
if he was a little convenient
bombilla um cool center of Education in
Amman it when you're in mostar make sure
you come in and check out the the
beautiful center here where you can
learn about Islam Muslims occur on any
other questions that you might have
ankle all right is everyone welcome of
course everybody was is welcome if you
have any questions about Islam you can
come here we will be happy to answer you
if we know if we don't know we will ask
somebody that knows and and deliver you
the message check out this tree here you
see one creator one God he created the
first man Adam and then you have all the
messengers got out of his love he sent
guidance he didn't leave us to figure it
on our own he sent messengers and they
all came with the same message worship
the Creator not the creation and prepare
for the day of judgment and after that
paradise Hellfire and that same where
life has always been their submission to
the will of the creator not the creation
and that summed up today with one word
Islam so this is that tree of the
prophets or all Muslims those who submit
their will to God it's been that same
message so I'm here with n Co and we
want to know what he just showed us the
Dawa Center here
what was it uncle with you now and you
know you're a young man
you're k1 fighter you left all that you
know and you you've been really active
you know and sharing the purpose of life
with people sharing his long cleared the
misconceptions out there you know doing
your best
what was it about Islam you know that
captivated you to have you really living
in now you know before I wasn't so so
religious then one person asked me
something about Islam
when she asked me what does what is this
letters letters you know where imam goes
and he do Futaba on Friday on drama I
said I don't know she asked me what is
this you know Mishra when worried mom go
and pray I said I don't know and I was
so was the name confused not confused I
was sorry that I couldn't answer her you
know yeah and then I started I talked
told myself I need to I need to learn
this what is this so next time somebody
asks me I can tell them so I start
learning about a little bit about Islam
and I start reading a biography of our
prophet muhammad sallallahu alayhi wa
sallam and more I read the more I get
love into it you know more I keep
reading it I couldn't stop and then like
day after day day after day every day I
was reading about Islam I was I was more
in love with it and then when I was like
17 18 I started praying you know and
alhamdulillah imagine now my life
without Islam without a lot protecting
me and it's like a new magic number you
took the time to start reading
investigating into the life of Prophet
Muhammad yes and I just fascinated
yeah and ever since you've been
establishing the prayer you it's it's
we're seeing a lot of youth are you
seeing that are also coming back to the
messages here how is it seems like you
know people before the message before
the were they were empty I'm hearing
that they're they're more phone of
course during the time before before war
it was like a shame to go to the Masjid
just the old people were going into the
message and the young people that were
going to the Masjid they harassed them
and they call them like old and like
they call them like grandpa one older
Muslim told me story about his life he
1970 in 1960 like that he used to go to
the message he used to pray he was like
15 16 years old in that time he told me
that his neighbors gather around and
always tease him you know because he's
he was going to the Masjid and you know
that was part but in that time there was
communism here and they took one all the
Roman like 60 year old woman 70 year old
woman and they get her bring her to him
and he said look we found your wife he
said I'm like 16 years old I don't want
some grandmother you know and they say
no you are always in in Masjid like
older guy you know like a grand grandpa
you need a grandmother now let's get
married let's let us get you married
with her and you will fulfill you like
your life and there was lot of it wasn't
easy to keep your religion in that time
now alhamdulillah
it's not not not easier to
become a Muslim living in Bosnia to ask
it if you ask somebody about Islam now
there was a lot of people that will
deliver the message to you that that
will answer your questions about Islam
if if you don't see some people to
answer you there are a lot of books or
TV shows or YouTube channels that that
can answer your questions about Islam as
from my case I was I didn't ask anybody
because oh I was a little bit afraid to
ask somebody because my my friends
didn't pray and like that you know so I
was afraid if I would ask them they
would tease me you know so I went to the
internet download some book of ceará you
know about life of prophet muhammad
sallallahoalyhiwasallam and i started
reading it and I say wow where was I
like 18 years where did I put my 18
years
why didn't I pray for 18 years you know
what was the purpose of my life I I
didn't have any purpose now
alhamdulillah I have and every day every
day I'm stronger and stronger on the
line in my religion in my faith and
inshallah now nothing can can stand
between me and Islam and you guys
experienced here what's one of the
number-one misconceptions that people
who know nothing about Islam maybe
people who might live here we don't you
know practice or people from the outside
who come in to visit the question that
they have a misconception about Islam as
we all know a lot of media as is giving
the bad picture about Islam so when they
see me it would be your day
always asked me they said this is new
religion which beer you know because
last maybe eighty years that there
wasn't like last sixty years there
wasn't a lot of Muslims with beard you
know because of austro-hungarian
austro-hungarian came here the Ottoman
Empire returned to Turkey and later
there was a few other governments like
there was a communist that was like one
or he then was Nazis I'm here in second
world world we were occupied by Germany
after that there was communism and all
of that government used to lower the
Islam in the hearts of the people you
know that was their main goal so when
they see me with beer they said you
imported religion from Saudi Arabia
Dennis
show them pictures about my
grand-grandfather that used to have you
know beard like hundred years ago 60 70
years ago all the women in in pasta used
to wear niqab you know here is called
the future
is the one of the types of makeup
they also don't show their eyes you know
they used to wear that in in in Bosnia
like for a lot of but a couple of
hundreds of years and they used all to
have beers and then when they say to me
I have a new religion like religion
imported from from some other countries
other I just said I'm traditional
Bosnian Muslim you know because my
great-grandfather were a beard because
mother of my grandmother she used to
wear any car you know so that's the
biggest misconception that people they
don't remember the time before like 1940
and they don't remember that time they
don't want to remember you know when
they see pictures day off of people with
beard but they not headache you know
because it's not something they they
want to accept you know they want to be
more modern they want to be more like
European style yeah like that it's it's
people like you before they know you
they have a big feel from you you know
they don't want to talk to you one years
when they see you with me when they know
you are Muslim they don't want to talk
to you but when you introduce yourself
to them in a right way you have a right
good talk to them they change God you
know they like lower their garden and
they start listening to you
start coming to their heart and slowly
slowly if they not changed the way of
the life on the better like changing
into being practical Muslim they change
their mind
and they don't know harassed other
Muslims and when somebody is talking bad
about Muslims they say no it's I talk to
a Muslim and I now know that things
aren't like that as they show on the
media Wow you come to another part of
the world and we're coming from the
states and we're dealing with a lot of
Islamophobia whatnot and they just show
the shift the change in the climate and
they got issues regarding the beard and
it's interesting that in the United
States it's actually fashionable
everybody has an almost seat on
celebrities and you know the ballplayers
Forsman it's like kind of the cool thing
so maybe they need to get but most of
all it's cool with God it's cool with
Allah you know all the prophets have
beards and why not but we have a lot of
issues you know that are out there that
we should be focused on one is
connecting with God you know pure
monotheism really knowing the purpose of
life living the purpose of life
establishing the prayer and unifying you
know as one Huma one community to work
towards a better place wherever we act
and I see that that's like you said
that's happening huh so what advice do
you have for people now who are young
they're motivated they got a lot of
energy and they look at you k1 fighter
sports menu changes it so you put so now
it's like the religion is becoming cool
to be you know religious that's the
coolest thing to be one who has
submitted to the will of God to know
your purpose but they're struggling you
know I mean what advice do you give to
the youth I want to advise them to be
open to everyone you know
but to have any barriers in inside of
your head if if something isn't clear
about somebody
don't ask another person about him go
away as him you know and if you wanted
to know about more about Islam start
don't look at what Muslims do you know
because a lot of Muslims don't represent
Islam in in the best light you know like
for example if you want to buy a car you
will not you will not look at what is
the good driver
that is driving that car you look how it
is good car or not
you understand it's like for Islam if
you want to know more about snarl not
look have a look for of some Muslims you
know you'll look about the best of the
men like prophet muhammad
sallallahoalyhiwasallam
my my advice to talk to young people
there that are interested in Islam is
just step by step
don't don't rush it don't take it too
much at once just go step by step if you
like love to listen to Islam once a week
go go listen to it now and say later on
if you like playing one one salat but
they play once a lot a day don't rush it
you know because if you if you rush it
too much it will be
if you take too much to be too much to
you and it will then be heavier to like
for athletes one day when they are
lifting weights for example bench
presser and everything you cannot live
like hundred kilos first day you come
you need to do every every training you
need to put more weight more more more
more and later you can you can lift 100
kilos it's the same with with Islam is
the same way with all of the things in
life if you are asking about Islam and
if you are interested start asking about
smaller things you know start asking
about who is the creator why am I on
this life don't start asking some
questions about I don't know polygamy or
beard or something
about what is she artists only what they
sell a few artists you know this
fractions and started asking simple
simple things like if you are going to
school and you are like second grade you
cannot read the book from university you
know it will just confuse you
it's like that on Islam if you are just
like one month into Islam you cannot
start learning things about that
some scholars the big scholars that are
like confused about you know you need to
go step by step in in your learning step
by step in your practicing and as it in
life you just need to take it easy one
letter after another one step after
second
thank you very much I hope you guys
benefited from his experiences to start
where Bosnia will keep inshallah God
willing meeting some wonderful people
and bringing you some of their
experiences and stories stay tuned sonic
you